dit que maçon
quant aux un monde
toca ligne
[Musique]
mais pas seulement en fait les personnes
à l'aquarelle à la colorimétrie et mon
but premier en fait c'est de puiser dans
la richesse de la faune et de la flore
par exemple ici dans ma propriété
pour réaliser des aquarelles donc tels
que des aquarelles botanique mais pas
que cela peut être aussi comme je le
disais en fait des animaux donc des
portraits et puis des réalisations plus
contemporaine aussi j'aime beaucoup
travailler en fait dans un cadre naturel
c'est important pour moi et pour la
lumière mais pas que on est aussi à
l'intérieur bon là évidemment avec la
chaleur ce qui à de sympathiques c'est
que voilà on peut trouver voyez derrière
le parc beaucoup dont brage donc
finalement on peut s'installer sur
l'herbe et à la limite l'aquarelle ce
qu'il y à 2
d'agréables finalement dans cet art là
c'est que l'on peut faire de l'aquarelle
sans dessein au préalable donc ça c'est
vraiment superbe il va falloir juste en
fait gérés les pigments et l'eau on peut
très bien réaliser une fleur sens
pratique et de dessins bien évidemment
pour l' architecture c'est plus
compliqué mais pour se faire plaisir
pour se détendre une fleur par exemple
dans le jardin voilà on peut très bien
réaliser une couronne de fleurs avec des
lavandes et roses trémières
d'autres styles de plantes et sans
dessein donc ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
je propose des ateliers
tous les après midi de 14 heures à 16
heures 30 sur rendez-vous cela peut-être
de ses heures 30 pour les personnes qui
travaillent à 18h30 le samedi matin donc
mais toujours sur réservation peut-être
aussi des ateliers en famille j'ai des
mamans par exemple vendredi après midi
qui vont venir avec le temps leurs
enfants respectifs donc ça c'est sympa
parce qu'on est aussi dans le partage
les adultes ont plus de facilité
quand on est à l'extérieur
qu'à l'intérieur les enfants c'est le
contraire un bien voir le décor de mon
atelier ça leur plaît énormément
regardez les aquarelles regarder les
animaux la taxidermie donc nous pouvons
nous rendre en fait dans les deux sèvres
dans la vienne et dans la charente et
charente-maritime pour étudier en fait
l' architecture de différentes églises
romanes datant du xiième siècle mais
aussi cela peut être un puits
cela peut être
une tour un pigeonnier donc voilà à
prendre aussi un peu des bases
architecture et les mettre en couleur
par chèque parce qu'en fait chaque
monument a comme par exemple ici des
pierres mais qui ont des coloris
différents mais souhaitait être affaibli
affiliés pardon à la marque poitou parce
qu'en fait cela me tient à coeur de
faire découvrir notre superbe patrimoine
nous avons vraiment une très très belle
région je suis
très intéressé par l'art roman du 12e
siècle donc là j'avoue que de ce côté là
nous sommes relativement gâté il y a de
quoi faire et je suis loin d'avoir fait
d'avoir réalisé tous les monuments fait
au mois de septembre je reprendrai mes
expositions
par exemple je serai conviés par le
département à la préfecture de poitiers
pour représenter en fait une grande
partie de mon travail sur l'
architecture du patrimoine mais pas que
ce soit aussi des planches botaniques
donc j'en suis ravi et vous pourrez me
retrouver aussi au salon de la déco à
poitiers et dans d'autres salons d'art
de la région
[Musique]